the calendar has always had one simple
purpose to keep us organized and maybe
to display cute puppy photos except now
between our multiple devices and our
work and personal calendars I need time
to organize my calendars the good news
is that there are more startups than
days of the week working to make the
calendar smarter but only a few are
solving my basic problems of syncing
consolidating and keeping my calendars
up to date the first thing I want to
easily manage my works Microsoft
Exchange calendar and my personal Google
Calendar in one central calendar that I
can view on my phone my tablet or my
laptop the native calendar apps for iOS
and Android do a good job of letting you
see all your calendars in one place but
outlook in Google make things harder on
the web or on a computer the native Mac
and Windows calendars are ok but don't
have any of the extras that many of
these new apps do unfortunately many of
these new calendar startups completely
ignore the web and desktop but not
magnito you take the terms no not that
one its web app actually allows not only
your exchange and Google calendars to
co-exist but actually communicate it
lets you take a personal appointment
like a spa visit and block it out on
your work calendar without sharing all
the personal details my second one just
an easier way to add things
magnito offers a cool trick on the web
install its Chrome extension highlight a
part of the page click the magnito
button and it will open an appointment
window with that information filled in
it also lets you easily send your
available times to friends and
colleagues mined offers a similar
feature sunrise partners with TripIt so
you don't have to input flight or hotel
info it just shows up where it's
supposed to but fantastical and tempo
make it the easiest to add events just
typing in lunch with Drew at 3:00
created a new event on my calendar so
once I've got those basics I want some
smarter tools ones that leverage the
power of the internet to get me to a
meeting on time and more prepared mind
magneto and son
I tell you how long it will take to get
to your next appointment Magneto even
builds it right into the schedule using
Google Maps data does it look like I'm
ready to go
sunrise in tempo also let you link your
Twitter Facebook or LinkedIn accounts
and it will surface photos or current
information on the people you'll be
seeing so that's what my dad looks like
of the many calendar apps I loaded up on
my phone tablet and laptop this week
magneto came the closest to making my
calendar headaches go away while sunrise
is available on more platforms magneto
is the first app to take steps towards
really merging our work and personal
calendars of course I could just go back
to paper and puppies hey guys I have a
meeting I need to be at can somebody let
me out of here